اذا حتى في عموم اوروبا اعياد الميلاد او
عيد الميلاد لن تكون ااا او لن يكون كسابق
سابقاته مع شبح الاضرابات المتواصله وازمت
الطاقه التي باتت المشكله الرئيسيه الذي
يقرا يقرق المسؤولين في البلاد في
بريطانيا الاضرابات تتصاعد وتيرتها بسبب
تراجع المستوى المعيشي وانخفاض الاجور
وتدهور القدره الشرائيه والارتفاع الشديد
في اسعار الغذاء والطاقه وفقا صحيفه
جارديان الاضرابات خلفت وراءها قلقا
حقيقيا بالنسبه للمسؤولين البريطانيين اما
في فرنسا والمانيا ازمه الطاقه تشتد قبيل
احتفالات عيد الميلاد حيث تمت دعوه
المواطنين للتقليل من مراسيم الاحتفالات
باعياد الميلاد وضروره ترشيد استغلال
الطاقه خصوصا وان بعض المدن الفرنسيه بدات
تسجل بعض الانقطاعات في شبكه الكهربه
كما ان بلجيكا هي الاخرى تشهد موجه من
الاحتجاجات او موجه من الاحتجاجات بسبب
التدابير الاخيره التي دعت اليها الحكومه
بخصوص ترشيد استهلاك الطاقه بالتزامني مع
اعياد الميلاد وراس السنه